لما يبدو ان ليلى العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
اصبح مثل انهارها هنا كل ما يقترب الليل
يتخوف سكان كياف من تجدد العمليات او
القصف عليها سواء بالسواريخ او طائرات
المسيره منذ ساعات من الان انطلقت صافيرات
الانذار هنا في اشاره الى تعرض كيف
والمناطق المجاوره لها
للقسوه للهجوم وفي اشاره الى بدء عمل
منظومه الدفاع الجوي طلب منا ان ننزل الى
القبو بقينا حوالي ثلاث ساعات في القبو
على ما يبدو او حسب الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه قد روسد الطائرات مقاتله روسيه
انطلقت منها الحدود البلار روسيه لم يتم
الاعلان عن وجهتها لهذا انطلقت صفيرات
الانذار هنا الماسات في اكياس ظاهره على
وجوه السكان تبدا الماسات من الليل خوفا
من تجدد القسوه في النهار مع انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي اكثر من ثلاث مرات ل همم
ليله امس انقطع التيار الكهربائي خمس
ساعات مستمره همم وانعدام الماء كل هذا
فاصبح من يوميات السكان هنا في اوكرانيا
ليله امس تحدثنا مع احد مسيري شركات توزيع
الكهرباء الذي قال لنا ان كل اكياف
العاصمه كيف تعمل فقط ب 20% من طاقتها في
توزيع الكهرباء وقال انه في حال لم تصل
المساعدات العاجله من الدول الغربيه
لاكيافوا لكل اوكرانيا فان سكان كياب وكل
سكان اوكرانيا سوف يقدرون شتاء اسود بمعنى
الكلمه الاوكرانيين اليوم يركزون فقط مع
العمليات العسكريه الموجوده في الحدود
البيلاروسيه وركزوا قبل يومين مع زياره
الرئيس الروسيه الى نظيره هي همم
يتخوفون مين تجدد العمليات العسكريه
الميدانيه من الحدود
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد القادر